what are some of your rules with
collaborating of the YouTuber door hey
could we meet for lunch and I just pick
your brain about my youtube channel i'm
sure you get all the time yeah yeah
we're sending rules yeah I actually
spoke thing called playlist live about
collaboration because that's I'm kind of
known for class I me I'm no more for my
collaboration as I am for my own videos
um you know my rules for collaboration
is if you wanna collaborate bring
something to the table you know it's
like asking someone out on a date and
being lucky you want to go to date yeah
sure what you want to do I don't know
it's the same thing and that's the
analogy I me down Florida uh yeah it's
just have you know i wanna collaborate
great what you want to do I don't know
well what you're saying is you just want
to do something and you want to share
audiences probably sharing more of mine
than me getting out of yours but if you
bring me something like hey I have
access to like a helicopter you want to
do without like great I don't even care
what it is it's something that I can't
normally do but I always bring something
I collaborate all the time but I always
I've you know I have scripts or I've
scripts and I have ways to kind of make
it worth their while um I you know
there's people that I've you know
especially in the comedy community that
I've met for lunch but a lot of times I
just say no I just can't I just can't do
it all the time you know if you know if
I've met with everyone that wanted to go
out to lunch you pick my brain I would I
would never do anything else I mean I've
gotten paid to consult and and stuff
like that and you know just like
anything like you know a paid
subscription my time does have a value
and I put I put a price on it you know
whether it's money or otherwise and for
me to like you know I kind of come up
with this kind of like loose a guideline
of me even working with some working
with someone it's like does it if it
pays money that's one thing um if it
grows my audience so it's just like you
know what I'm going to reach the
audience I would normally get and three
it's just an awesome project and if I
can get all three of those things that's
a jackpot you know but I need to have at
least one otherwise it's a I just can't
do it and if I can hit you know all
three or two out of three that's great
that being said and knowing that
he will probably do gravitate towards
you and our that I don't know what to do
and it's really about sort of riding off
your audience right how do you politely
turn them down because there's so many
you know we're all sensitive and we're
all we all have egos sure I I mean you
know and it's not it's not far-fetched
but it's just like I will you know I you
know just like you know i love doing so
I mean I never like this in sometimes
I'm just like it's not is not doesn't
really fit what I do but I just really
don't have the time I mean um you know
I'll take and I'll read it and sometimes
and and check it out but for the most
part I I really just don't have the I
just don't have to I don't have the time
or the energy to do it and you know
they'll get to that point where they
won't have the time energy just like I
was at a point where you know I just
would say yes to anything i just wanted
to do do do do um and the other people
you know we're like my time's running
out so they'll they'll get to that point
where they have to say no as well i
think do you remember that day cuz it's
a wonderful probably it's like problems
of prosperity its order have everybody
wanting you but i'm sure there was
probably some chaotic moment when we
said no more um yeah I remember just
like trying to know I was doing improv I
was auditioning and I was like I mean
I'll take it slow down just recently but
um I remember from january second maybe
the end of februari shot like 67 videos
or 70 72 videos something like that I
shot a lot of videos in two months um
and uh you know it was at that point I
was just like wow I am doing a lot
they're all worth they're all great and
worth doing and you know some were just
just for me and a lot for other people
but I knew that was gonna get was gonna
kind of like keep me afloat you know I
was gonna keep those audiences engaged
keep people looking at my stuff and
keeping me as relevant as possible um
but yeah I hit those things but I don't
really think about it as much now have
so many other things um that I don't
care as much about being in front of the
camera in fact my preference now lately
is to be developing and I have ownership
in something you know someone should do
a video and literally you do it and you
acted it's gone it's somebody else's and
it's out the ether for me I want to like
create and be part and own something so
that's kind of like my current um my
current endeavors as well as you know
still still acting
doing comedy and such
you